oui avec le retrait des troupes
américaines du sol allemand donald trump
cherche donc à punir l'allemagne entre
autres pour sa volonté d'importer du gaz
russe mais aussi son soutien à la
construction du gazoduc nord stream de
l'allemagne se retrouverait donc si on
en suit le raisonnement américains plus
exposés plus vulnérables sans la
présence des troupes américaines mais
plus vulnérables à quoi telle est la
question posée par le représentant russe
auprès des instances internationales
regarder certains observateurs
interprètent le retrait de 12 mille
soldats américains d'allemagne comme une
punition pour berlin pourquoi
l'allemagne n'est pas menacé
ainsi la sécurité ne sera pas affectée
politiquement l'allemagne en profitera
probablement cela ne peut affecter
économiquement que les communautés
autour des bases américaines
on assiste donc un dangereux mélange des
genres du côté de washington pour
empêcher la russie de continuer à
exporter son gaz vers l'allemagne puis
vers le reste de l'europe
donald trump brandi l'otan et bouleverse
les équilibres sur le vieux continent
une décision dont on est sans doute
encore loin d'avoir mesuré toute
l'ampleur
c'est une affaire domestique des états
unis et c'est une question de relations
bilatérales entre washington et berlin
nous ne pouvons pas commenter ces
relations et nous ne nous immisçons pas
nous n'avons jamais caché que moins il
ya de militaires américains en europe
fut la situation il sera stable notre
position est bien connu d'autant plus
qu'après la confrontation entre les deux
blocs durant la guerre froide
il n'ya plus de menace évidente est réel
les menaces éphémère on peut les
inventer à loisir on assiste donc un
dangereux mélange des genres du côté de
washington pour empêcher la russie de
continuer à exporter son gaz vers
l'allemagne puis vers le reste de
l'europe
donald trump brandi l'otan et bouleverse
les équilibres sur le vieux continent
une décision dont on est sans doute
encore loin d'avoir mesuré toute
l'ampleur